[Music]
my name is Asha colourfully I'm a
psychologist and a relationship
researcher from bar-ilan University in
Israel I've been involved with the hope
and optimism initiative for the past
couple of years as one of the grantees
on the social science side this
initiative funded a research project
that we are nearing the completion of
now it's a study looking at couples in
the transition to Parenthood couples who
are expecting their first child who
would follow for a period of time
starting in the third trimester of
pregnancy all the way through at this
point six months postpartum were
actually hoping to continue this work
and be able to follow them through one
year and then two years after the child
is born and we do this work both because
we're really interested in this
population of couples in this juncture
of time is so full of expectations but
also fears and dreads so we're
interested in the population and we're
also interested in this quality of hope
and then trying to see through a use of
of this population to see something
about the nature of hope to try and
understand something about what is hope
at the level of not just one individual
but in this case a couple or family and
emerging family we have three premises
that guide our work two of them are
already underway and the third one is
more of a future direction that we're
hoping to to pursue the two that are
underway are looking at hope is more
than just a stable quality and
individual characteristic that
differentiates one person from another
or maybe one couple from another and
instead recognizing that hope has this
fluctuating component to it that it
could change over time that there are
ways in which the stability or
instability in it beyond just its set
level it could be really interesting and
important this dynamic quality of hope
is one thing we're looking at and we do
that by having these partners these
couples tell us about their hope
expectation and optimism repeatedly we
do this both in the longest range of
things so following them from pre
pardon through postpartum over the
course of these basically nine months
from the third trimester through six
months after birth but also for a period
of time around three months after they
give birth we have them complete daily
Diaries for a period of three weeks
where we look at fluctuations on a daily
basis we ask them to report their own
feelings and to impute feelings about
their partner so that we'll be able to
see how these things change from moment
to moment so that's one premise or one
idea that we have in our work a second
idea that I alluded to earlier is the
idea that hope is more than just an
individual characteristic that there's
something about it that could be
interesting to explore to understand at
the level of a system dyad in this case
a pair of people we're curious whether
hope is contagious for that you need
these two people's reports of their own
hopes to see whether one person's hope
affects the other over time we were
wondering whether it's compensatory
whether the the presence of hope for one
could carry the day carry them through
difficult periods like the sleepless
days that come after birth or the
prepartum period where there's often a
lot of anxiety but what this will be
like what parenting will become like is
it enough for one person to have hope
for both partners or do we really need
it to be high for both those are two
premises that we have the data for at
least in part we're still waiting for
the last of those couples in our sample
to complete the three months and six
months postpartum but thankfully all the
people that we recruited in this study
have by now given birth to healthy
babies which was a relief and and we've
been starting to look at the data mostly
from the pre pardon phase at this point
so the data before the child was born
and we saw some interesting things
already one of them is that it seems
that it's the expectant mothers hope
much more so than the expectant fathers
that seems to have effect both for
themselves so for the these expectant
mothers themselves
their sense of relationship satisfaction
their sense of well-being in the world
was tied to their own hope but so was
their partners so the women's Hope
seemed to have both a direct effect on
their own feelings well-being
satisfaction and on their partners and
we didn't find the counterpart effect
from the men's hope in other words
there's something about this period
maybe and we'll have to see whether it's
just this period that gives extra weight
to hope on these expectant mothers more
than the expected father's side one of
the things we want to explore is whether
this will shift maybe even maybe even
flip over or at least balance itself out
postpartum we think it might we think
that there's something about the kind of
experience that expectant mothers have
that just by the sheer fact that they
are the one carrying the baby that makes
them much more connected to thinking
about what parents would be like
thinking about the baby and that the
father's in a sense may not be quite
getting it until after childbirth
happens after they become parents so
we're expecting that something will
change with this postpartum and it may
be that the greater exhaustion that that
new mothers seem to have may wash out
this effect of hope maybe there won't be
much hope we do see some drops in hope
postpartum from what we've peaked at but
really it's too early to tell whether
whether it's really a serious drop or
just a minor drop in hope levels okay so
these two premises that we've been
exploring in data are that hope
fluctuates that it's dynamic and that
hope is a quality of the couple that
it's dyadic we have a third premise but
that's one that we're going to be
exploring in our next project we're
really interesting to see whether we're
really interested to see whether hope is
malleable whether we can change it and
to do that we're planning a study that
applies some research on mental imagery
hope is a strong imagery component as
many of the other speakers at the saw at
this festival have talked about there's
a daydreaming component there's an
imaginal component
to hope and we are emphasizing this
imaginal component in this next piece of
our work we want to see whether we can
train people in this case couples to
imagine their desired outcomes these
things that they hope for in a more or
less effective way we're going to be
doing this as a randomized study where
some of the couples receive this I think
seemingly logical intervention of like
let's imagine the future and let's think
about these positive outcomes that that
will happen which on the face of it
sounds like would be a way to increase
hope but in reality is going to be or we
think is going to be less effective than
a different kind of intervention where
we have to imagine these desired
outcomes but we also have them imagine
the obstacles and the way to get around
these obstacles to get to these outcomes
work from motivational psychologists and
health psychologists has shown that this
sort of process it's often called mental
contrasting where you think about what
you want you really imagine it but you
also think about what's going to block
your progress towards that desired goal
leads to more effective hope leads to
more effective accomplishment of these
things that people want for themselves
we want to see whether this happens here
we want to see whether doing this in the
context of a relationship where we'll
we'll have one of probably one of my
graduate students PhD students in
psychology delivering this but in the
presence of the partner as well so we're
gonna have both partners in the room and
we'll switch and do a similar kind of
intervention with both of them in mind
whether this kind of work can actually
increase hope in a sustainable way and
lead them to accomplish or fulfill the
expectations that they have for what it
would be like to be parents and for what
we like to be a couple after the child
has arrived in a more effective way
[Music]